welcome everyone to data mesh and
practice
hi i'm joined here today by aviva
and we are going to talk about how
europe's leading online platform for
fashion
goes beyond the data lake is where
i would like throw a couple questions
into the room to get like
a hands up on things like who knows
salando
who knows salando as a tech company but
unfortunately due to this
remote circumstances that we are in
right now um
i have to stick to just give you a
little bit of
a one-sided information on the company
i'm working for as well so who's the
lundo in general zelano was found as a
startup about 12 years ago
to sell shoes online but
it started growing pretty rapidly
and by now is one of the
biggest online retailers to sell
fashion in general uh but not only that
but even going beyond
and um offering these services that it
has built up over the years
um also for for other retailers and thus
really becoming a platform uh
for fashion professional sales online
um so the interesting part is that
the company by now has more than 14 000
employees
of which more than two in tech alone
and this is um really interesting
because it only showcases how much of a
like almost big player in tech at least
in europe
uh zalando has become over the years but
this also shows
uh what is our internal
um audience that we are usually working
with
when we are talking about data
infrastructure
who are we i am max schroedzer i'm a
lead data engineer
at zalando and i've been working with
the company for about
four and a half years now i've been
working
on the data lake project of the company
throughout all this time
starting from initial build up of the of
the project
but then also growing and evolving it
over time um into more decentral
approaches
and this is exactly what we also want to
uh showcase here today
has been the journey that we went
through and what are the things
that we arrived at and that we also
currently working on uh
moving forward just a little fun fact
about myself
i'm all into gaming so if you have
anything that you want to
discuss either about computer games
games card games i'm
uh young man i'm usually i like to
present myself as a retired
semi-professional magic to-gathering
player
so if you want to have some follow-up
questions about this one
feel free to hook me up afterwards arif
do you want to present yourself
yes hi i'm a reef i'm a developer and a
consultant with thoughtworks
and with artworks
we the london thoughtworks we've been
together working on
data topics for about the last nine
months
and i'm also serving as the head of ai
for thoughtworks germany and i guess
if there is some one thing that i'm
really passionate about next to
software and i.t then this would
certainly be coffee
so um you can certainly ping me about
that and i guess i'm kind of missing a
little bit
the usually excellent coffee that was
served at
ndc oslo in oslo so hopefully
we can have that next year again so
before we get going let me say a few
very quick words about thoughtworks
so thoughtworks as it's at its core is
an
i.t consultancy we're a bit smaller than
the really big
consultancies but we are a truly global
company
with offices in more than 14 countries
and i guess what makes us stand out a
bit
is that we truly believe in the power of
diversity
and that we can actually make the world
a better place through what we do
and another thing that we um
truly believe in is open knowledge and
i guess that is one of the reasons why
thought workers in general
are quite active in terms of writing
books on i.t topics
but also speaking at conferences like
here
and also writing articles
and actually one of those articles
is the article how to move beyond a
monolithic data
lake to a distributed data mesh that was
published
pretty much a year ago and written by
jean-marc degani a colleague of mine in
the us
and so that article introduces the
data mesh as a so to say successor
paradigm
to the central data lake and that
article and the concept attracted quite
some
attention at zalando at the time and
i guess this is therefore one of the
reasons why we're here
together today talking about that topic
and so that brings me to what you can
expect uh from this talk today
so first max will tell you a little bit
the story of the of zalando's cloud and
analytics journey and
how this went over the last couple of
years because
what you need to understand is that
as much as the data mesh concept didn't
appear out of thin air so to say but
instead emerged from the experiences
that we made with our clients
zalando ethelando there were already
quite a few developments
that are going into the direction of the
data mesh idea
and this is probably also one of the
reason why it resonated so much with the
folks at zalando
so then afterwards i will give you a bit
of an idea about the individual concepts
of the data
paradigm so i will go a bit into that
and then afterwards hand it
back to max again who will tell you more
about what we're actually doing at the
london and what the folks
especially in the data infrastructure
platform team are doing
to move solando closer to that idea of a
distributed data mesh
so this is where you go on markz
thanks erie for the quick intro so as i
already mentioned
i want to take you a little bit on the
journey here on
how does analytics actually started
developing where we are coming from
uh how the whole cloud looked like and
then what was the
the state that we were in when we
started thinking about how the whole
data mesh idea
so as i already said before when uh when
it comes to current numbers
zelando is having around more than 2000
people actually working in tech
and each of these is potentially a
customer of the central data
infrastructure
and this is quite interesting because
that of course
shows the scale that we are operating in
actually so we are really talking about
like
terabytes of data every day we are
talking about the total storage size
of uh around 10 to 15 petabytes of data
we're talking about thousands of data
sets but of course this
did not right away start like this right
um originally the company was
much smaller but already had a very
strong
focus on data like a lot of decisions
were based on data a lot of data was
collected all the time
but the whole setup at the very
beginning was much simpler
originally the whole company was running
in a single data center
where there was like a monolithic
application
for the shop um there was a lot of parts
of that which
were providing different services which
each had their own backend databases
and then there was one big central data
warehouse where data was collected
to do reporting analytics
and actually provide information to base
decisions on
this was quite simple set up for that
regard because
if you're running within the boundaries
of the same data center
you can always directly let's say open
up a jdbc connection to your backend
database
fetch the the data that you're actually
interested in
usually in 90 etl jobs bump it into your
data warehouse have like huge reports
being generated a lot of data
aggregation happening
um and then you're good to go
this became a bit challenging when the
landlord started to scale
and eventually we hit the boundaries
where we needed more flexibility in
terms of
resources that the data center couldn't
offer anymore and even a single data
warehouse
was at some point just becoming too
small for all the data that
was actually valuable for analytics
and that's when the first step of the
evolution started and
the decision was essentially made to
move the company to the cloud
the interesting point here is that that
of course means
that all the services which were usually
before running together and easily
accessible were now running in separate
environments
uh at the beginning every team actually
had their own aws account
so then those mostly running on aws i
should say here um
and they had separate environments where
they were operating their services and
where they are operating also their
local data stores and they were not so
easily reachable anymore because you
could
usually if at all only talk to the
public internet so you didn't have like
all these direct connections that you
had before anymore
and that's when the decision also was
made to build a company-wide messaging
bus
i think that's a pretty common pattern
um that many companies actually went
through
um but the interesting thing here of
course was that the first
purpose of this messaging bus was to act
as the communication channel
between these microservices which no
longer had a chance to directly talk to
each other
of course at that time we also realized
that this messaging bus
already contains a lot of the valuable
information
that the company is producing and then
soon after the second purpose was added
to take this as the first
big source of data for a new found data
lake in the company
a little bit fast forward what do i
actually mean when i was
talking about a data lake of zalando
usually i'm dividing this into three
areas which is ingestion
connection to the sources data pipelines
that actually bring you the data in
there's the storage layer um and then
there's a serving layer on top of that
which allows you to actually access the
data
and do some processing with it and to
fill this with some details
um what were the main ingestion
pipelines that we that we had at that
time
well the first one i already talked
about um there is this
there was a central event bus um that we
had
one pipeline connecting to that
essentially was
archiving all the data that was flowing
through this event
so every everything that was published
there was a copy archived in the in the
central archive of the data lake
the second big source that we collected
was actually the
legacy data house that at that time was
still running in the data center
there has been like i don't know eight
or ten years
of logic built up in this original data
warehouse
and of course it's not that easy to just
like snap a finger and move everything
to the cloud
like a lot of this logic that has been
built up
is very much worth preserving and a lot
of the
output of the aggregated data sets which
i also have to admit some of them are
even still running today
um are still so valuable that it's uh
it totally makes sense to have a copy of
this data also
available in the data for a broader
audience
on the accessing site and the last but
not least
pipeline to actually collect web
tracking information
about the users which are visiting the
zalando site
this information is highly valuable when
you for instance combine it with some
sales information from the other sources
to identify
certain patterns on the buying side
or general user behavior
when i'm talking about storage um as i
already mentioned the lundo is
almost exclusively running on aws so for
that matter it was pretty easy for us to
actually define the big storage backend
that we were because we were actually
looking for a
simple storage solution and went in
aws s3 um that was like kind of cheap
and still had the potential to easily
scale a lot
when talking about storage it's not just
about storage
of the data itself but also of the
metadata that comes with it
so even starting with simple technical
metadata like
size of my data sets a schema of the
data that is actually published
um how do different data sets connect
with each other
and then even high-level descriptions of
what what the data is actually about
uh so that people can analyze this and
start using the data more easily
and then on the third side on the on the
serving side we essentially have a
split up for uh for um
querying access of the data when you
when you just want to crunch
the numbers and produce some results and
have like talk access to the data
that's what we are using presto for um a
lot of the data analysts are quite
familiar with sql interface
so presto has a distributed sql engine
is serving us quite well to actually
fulfill exactly this purpose
and the interesting part then is we have
the second part
where what we call the databricks
processing platform
essentially what that is is we are
operating spark as a service for other
teams
and that is spark run through databricks
which is one of our partners um where we
are offering
where we have a central offering of
compute capacity
uh operated by a central team but then
given to the users
who then essentially can use this
compute capacity to do whatever they
uh whatever they need to do um to
achieve their part
this is mostly for data transformation
so this is like the the big
jobs which are actually processing data
and doing like a bunch of things like
pre-aggregations
and transformation of data and then last
but not least we also have a catalog
which is usually
a starting point on the discovery side
for actually
getting your data journey rolling
centralization has certain challenges
this is what we realized over the years
of operating this system
where we were facing more and more
issues when
it really comes to looking at who's
actually working with the data
so usually you have three perspectives
of people who are working with data the
one
are the data producers um the one who
actually well
yes produced the data there is the
central infrastructure team
which in our case were was responsible
for not only archiving the data
but also giving the access um and then
there were the actual users
who well want to actually use the data
and this creates like sort of a
disconnectedness between the users and
the consumers
because in the end the infrastructure
team they don't actually know so much
about the data they are dealing with
that's why we usually um call them data
agnostic infrastructure teams
but when you then have a user that wants
to use a certain data set and
they want to learn about this data set
they would usually just reach out to the
infrastructure team
but the infrastructure team doesn't
really feel that
and a ownership for the uh for the data
sets they are dealing with because
again we are dealing with thousands of
data sets you cannot know everything
about all those data sets right
but then again the actual producers of
the data they also didn't really feel
a certain sense of ownership because
well they were just producing some data
centering it let's say to the central
event bus
and then there was a central park
pipeline that was archiving the data
and some of the producers didn't even
know that their data was archived they
didn't even know that they had users
and of course this created lack of
ownership um
which was really problematic at times
at the same time with this lack of
ownership also comes a certain lack of
quality
because um the data infrastructure team
which is operating all these pipelines
they usually check like on a higher
level if everything is working fine
is the pipeline working fine is the data
properly processed
but they don't actually run data quality
checks for every single data set
and because there's again this
disconnectedness between the the
producers of this data
where usually these issues from um
and the actual consumers of the data
which are now facing these issues
uh it's really hard to actually get them
together without the involvement of the
infrastructure team themselves and leads
to the third big issue that we were
actually facing which is
well the central team becomes the
bottleneck
whenever there is an issue on the user
side they don't know about who's
actually the actual producer or
the owner of this data and um they reach
out to the central infrastructure team
and that actually leads to the position
that the central infrastructure team
then needs to acquire certain knowledge
about the data
the domain is coming from to dive deep
into specific issues
related to single data sets and of
course this does not scale
right and um looking at these three
um issues that we were facing here over
time i will actually now
hand it back to aries to tell us a bit
more about
these issues and how they can be seen on
a more global scale
great thanks max
so having been a consultant
over the years and therefore also having
been a member of
several data teams over the years
i can really say that those challenges
that
max just described are really very very
common
so in fact i have seen that situation in
pretty much every single
data platform team that i've been with
that had central data ownership
and so what much just described is
really a recurring pattern that we can
see
so if we step back a little bit we have
those three parties that max mentioned
we have the data producing
teams on the left and so those are
really the
the product teams right that uh built
products
um that built uh reliable systems
and they are kind of okay usually with
the situation
um because they have their own
incentives
and they are so to say happily
generating data right
and then on the right side you have the
data consumers and actually sometimes
those data consumers are the product
teams as well than when they
want to work in a data driven fashion
but those are often decision makers or
data scientists for instance
and they are already
feeling the consequences and
duplications of those
ownership and data quality issues that
max mentioned right
so um they work with the data and they
really um then complain that something
is not wrong or the data quality is not
right
so they're already struggling a little
bit but then the third party which is
this
kind of uh usually team of data
engineers maintaining such a central
data platform
they are really the ones who are in a
quite tight spot
because they have the responsibility to
provide
reliable fresh data to the data
consumers
but at the same time they are often
constantly doing firefighting and
dealing with issues
that have been introduced because of
changes
coming from the data producing teams
and then trying to solve some problem
where
they are really not the experts on right
they don't really know what the data
means
and they try to solve a problem um and
at the same time they are the ones where
the data consumers will come to right
data consumers will rightfully so
complain and
will come to the to the central team and
ask what's wrong there
so this is really quite an unfortunate
situation that
those central data teams find themselves
in
quite often and
interestingly that it doesn't matter
whether this is
a central data warehouse or central data
lake that you're building there
because the problem is the
centralization itself
and to be precise this is not
necessarily
about the technical centralization this
is about the central
ownership because simply when you
imagine that you have on the left
the data consumers and the number of
data consumers
ever growing in a thriving company right
more and more data is being generated
and then you have on the right side
you have the number of data consumers
also ever growing in the company that is
thriving to be data driven so more and
more people want to do things with data
and then you have this central data
platform in the middle
with which will eventually become this
bottleneck and really
doesn't scale very well but now what is
actually the reason
for this to scale that bad
the reason is that a central data team
or a central data platform that also has
central ownership of data
is essentially a data monolith that
cuts through domains and so to give an
example here
let's imagine we have a checkout service
here
on the data producing site right and
um this checkout service is built by a
team of developers um and
they maintain this checkout service and
they have their own database
so their own data and they also generate
checkout events
those checkout events um end up in the
central data platform
so now you see that is one domain
about checkout knowledge right or um
about checkout data that this is
scattered across multiple teams
it's to one part it belongs to the team
or even several teams
uh maintaining those production services
about checkout activities
and another part of it is owned
or it is in the realm of responsibility
of that central
data team and that really means that
kind of the boundary of this
central data platform cuts through this
domain right away
and that creates a lot of friction
misunderstandings and ultimately
prevents this model
from scaling
and coming from those observations that
we've seen again and again
what is the data mesh now about so the
data mesh concept
really is as i mentioned from the
beginning
it's a concept that we came up with
seeing good approaches
happening at our most progressive
clients and
bringing them all together so
interestingly the data mesh concept is
really mostly
about ideas
or to to apply ideas that we have
already successfully
applied to the software engineering
domain over the last couple of years
but to now apply them on data challenges
which has not been the case before
and really three key innovations here
are to apply product thinking domain
driven distributed architecture and
infrastructure as a platform to data
and i will go through them now one by
one
so let's start with the first one
product thinking and i want to start
with that one because i believe that is
also really the one
that can help the most with those
ownership issues that marx mentioned and
the idea is quite simple
so you want to treat a data set
as a product so what does that mean that
means
that you need to answer product specific
questions
so for instance what is the market for
my data
um but also um therefore what who are my
cost customers right and what are their
needs but then also things like how do i
even make sure that my customers know
about my offering right how do i do
marketing and ultimately even things
like
what is even my usp so how do i
distinguish my data offering from other
data offerings in the company
and so to thoroughly tackle those kind
of product questions about data you
usually
want to have a dedicated person dealing
with this and that would be a data
product
manager and so now this data product
manager should be
part of a cross-functional team building
and maintaining
such a data product as an autonomous
service basically
and that means you will have data
engineers
infrastructure engineers etc working
together
to build data pipelines for instance
but also to create documentation
and generally provide all the
capabilities to make this
data available to their customers
so now the second key idea here
is to apply domain driven distributed
architecture or domain driven design
to data so what does that mean here it
means that such a
data product must be focused on
a clearly defined domain
and must really look at what are the
domain boundaries and what is the
bounded context here
so the underlying idea here
is that when you build a data product
around
one such a domain then that means that
the team
building that data product that they can
become
domain experts and that will lead to the
good situation that you can solve
data problems where you need domain
specific knowledge about the data
right at the place where this domain
specific knowledge is
and this is really quite an enabler when
it comes to scaling
data solving data problems
and now you want
such data products to become the
fundamental building block
of a distributed mesh of such data
products right
and that means you can have data
products for domains you can have data
products for sub
domains um depending on how complicated
the domains are and how many people you
need
to to deal with them and you can have
different kind of domains so typically
you have
what we call source oriented
data products that means those are
a domains that are very much centered
about the specific knowledge of
how certain data gets captured right so
for instance an
example here would be web tracking um
depending on what you use to capture the
data
there are quite some intricacies that
you need to know about in order to
make sure the data quality is right and
and to provide it in a
high quality and reliable fashion and so
this specific knowledge
is then captured in such a source
oriented data domain
and in the respective team but then on
the other hand
you can also have so-called aggregated
data domains and so those are kind of
higher order
domains that usually build on top
of existing source aligned
data domains so an example here could be
for instance
i don't know maybe a recommendation
maybe recommendation data
something that really builds on on other
data and creates more value
but that is still interesting and
complex enough that it justifies
um to be treated as an as a separate
domain
that has separate domain expertise
so now this
idea of such a mesh of individual domain
focused data
products has quite some similarity to
the idea of a microservice architecture
and kind of similar to
microservices not
every micro not every service is
automatically a micro service at least
not
in the way how we understand these terms
today right
you want a microservice to be
independently deployable
you wanted to have slos etc those kind
of things this is really what we
understand these days
what a service has to have in order to
be a proper microservice
and the same is kind of a similar thing
is true for
data products there are certain things
you want to have in place
before you can call something a data
product
so one of those things for instance
would be to be discoverable
you need to be able to find the data
then you need to be able to address the
data so that you can actually
work with it and in order for this whole
thing to scale
it needs to be self-describing right and
then furthermore of course it needs to
be secure and trustworthy
and all of this is for the
ultimate goal which is to be
interoperable because that is really
kind of the key thing of this mesh to
scale and to work out
is that the individual data products
need to be interoperable
and this is also similar to the
microservice idea
where usually you have really
interoperability at the core of the
success of the microservice
architecture pattern
so and that brings me to kind of the
third
key concept here which is self-service
data infrastructure
and generally the the main motivation
here to provide
a data infrastructure platform
is to avoid that each of those
autonomous
data products that they need to build
up their own infrastructure and have
kind of duplicate efforts right
and this is um from the general idea
really not
very new and this is really what the
public cloud providers are doing all the
time they provide self-service
um platforms to come up with your
to provision your infrastructure
now what is important in this particular
setup
is that such a data infrastructure
platform
doesn't become a data platform so
it needs to stay domain agnostic
and that means basically when you're for
instance an engineer
part of the team building such a data
infrastructure platform
and you realize that you need to have
some
domain knowledge about one of those data
products in order to solve a problem
then that is probably a sign that you
are already on the
in going in the wrong direction again
where you're on the way to building the
next
monolithic data platform with central
data ownership and this is really
what you don't want instead you want
this data
infrastructure platform to provide
domain agnostic
self-service tools and capabilities that
really enable
autonomous teams building data products
and so for instance a good indicator of
how well
you're providing such a data
infrastructure platform is
how quickly can a team
create a new data product or the
infrastructure
for a new data product simply using the
means that the data infrastructure
platform is providing without having to
contact the people maintaining the data
infrastructure platform
but really just using those self-service
tools
and now all of this has to be
governed by some global governance and
global standards but the key thing to
keep in mind here is
that this global governance should
really
only be for or should mainly be there
for
enabling interoperability so
at the point where kind of you're doing
too much
governance um at the central place
you're working against the scalability
and against
autonomy of the individual teams and
data products again
so you need to make sure you're only
doing as much
central governance as is needed to
provide this interoperability for this
ecosystem
of data products to thrive
and now before i will hand it back to
max who will really tell you more
specifically from that perspective of
the data infrastructure platform
let me wrap up a little bit and
highlight one thing the data
mesh paradigm is really more a mindset
shift and not so much
a technological shift so
the data mesh idea is about going from
centralized data ownership to
decentralized data
ownership it's about not looking at
technical things like pipelines as the
fast as the first class concern anymore
to structure your data
landscape but instead to look at domains
as the first class concern to structure
your data landscape and your data
structures and it means
that data is not a byproduct anymore but
really becomes
the product and this means that you want
to go away from
siloed data engineering teams that are
building their central
uh data platform but instead you have
cross-functional teams with data
engineers in them
that build those data products and
ultimately that means
you go away from a centralized data lake
to an
ecosystem of data products
and i'm giving it back to max here
thanks ari for this uh great
introduction to
we actually mean when we talk about this
data mesh and the concepts
behind that and now uh as i have already
said
um i would like to highlight a little
bit of
what are the as part of this concept
that we already
um had the chance to to put to practice
and here i'm also specifically focusing
on this infrastructure perspective uh
because that is exactly the team that
i'm representing here as well
just to give you a quick recap uh once
more we were originally coming from this
uh central infrastructure there's always
been a bottleneck
that was always contacted by all the
users and the producers
whenever there was an issue on either
side but what we actually wanted to get
was
as i just described to become a data
infrastructure
platform team that does not need to
actually dive deep into these details
all the time
but that just provides infrastructure
that people can then use by themselves
at the same time going very with the
same idea
we wanted to get away from the central
data platform and from this
actual data monolith we like to call it
as well
towards these interoperable services
just to uh show you a little bit of how
how we started got moving in this
direction i want to essentially
pick off where i where i left off with
your original problem statement
and take you again back to the to the
journey that we've been following
specifically over the last uh months and
years
so what we started off
are the components that already existed
in our central databank
so there was special data lake storage
there was several petabytes of data
already that were stored in central
places that were still very valuable
to the rest of the company and of course
we didn't want to throw that away
just to spread the data but
this was very valuable information that
will of course need to be kept around
and also on top of that we already had
like a a metadata layer
that was covering um the whole data that
was already stored there
um this was again like about all these
additional information that you keep
about the data which is not part of the
data themselves
like descriptions high level of what
these data sets are about and how they
can be used
but this also included a governance
layer
in terms of having clear descriptions
about let's say
which data sets actually contain
confidential information but also the
whole access management around this so
who was actually allowed to see certain
confidential information
we already had something in place that
was working very well
um to actually follow these kind of
processes
so the next step that we actually wanted
to do was
we wanted to add more data easier
and directly provided by the teams who
actually own the data
and that's why we went with a concept
that internally we called
bring your own byob to have a more fun
description
to enable people to share the data sets
that they store in their own buckets in
their own accounts
with this already centrally provided
infrastructure
and here we got good help
from uh how aws specifically s3
structured in the back end because all
our services are actually running in the
same region
uh which means that s3 in the back end
is not
actual like physical separation of the
data but it's much rather
a logical separation between these
different accounts
but accessibility of this data across
account boundaries
is very easy if you have the proper
access rights
and this enabled us to essentially allow
people
to do exactly that bring their own
buckets and share that with the with the
central
um with the central buckets and just put
them together next to each other
and this already was the first step to
foster a culture of increased ownership
for the data sets
because if i am the one who actually
stores the data by myself
and i know now that this data is also
used by somebody
else then i have already an increased
ownership and a decreased responsibility
for also providing proper quality but
for also interacting with my users more
often
the second big step um when we started
building up on
something that we already started are
these
uh process platforms that i already
mentioned
so here we are providing infrastructure
to other teams without actually needing
to learn about what they are
doing with it so we have the central uh
presto infrastructure in place where
users just get an interface where they
can fire
sql queries against data sets but when
they actually have some questions
around the data sets they will not talk
to the infrastructure teams but they
will talk to the actual data owners
and even more so with the with the spark
processing platform
that we are running on data breaks here
we are
providing clusters for teams by
just following templated definitions so
the team needs to tell us
how big should the cluster be who should
get access to the cluster
which kind of data sets this cluster
should get access to but then
like based on such templates we just
create a cluster for the team
and yes we operated in a central way so
not that every
i think around 100 teams that we already
have which is using this right now
uh have to all first build up a smart
cluster by themselves and maintain it
themselves
this is not necessary but once we head
over the usage to the the
to the actual requesters like the
central team does not
all know anymore what they're actually
doing and they don't need to and that's
the great part here because
um they can completely act independently
from the platform team
while the platform team is literally
just doing that providing
a platform what we
wanted to foster even more um and that
was like
the next step in our journey here was
that we essentially we just wanted to
simplify
data sharing across technologies
and here we went an approach where
because we already had this
this metadata slash governance layer
which more and more just became an
interface for data um
it was much easier to actually connect
additional technologies like
for instance if you want to also some
data that you are storing in your
rds database or if you want to connect
your redshift
to some central s3 source just to load
some data in your
localized domain data warehouse
and this was the whole idea how we
started like adding
more parts just because we had the
chance to have this
infrastructure interface which could be
easily used by all the teams
who needed to get involved with it
so just to summarize a little bit on
what the ideas were from
the technical changes that we made here
was
again exactly what arief mentioned
before we wanted to go
with central services that had global
interoperability
and here the important thing to actually
figure out was that
decentralized ownership does not
necessarily mean decentralized
infrastructure
you still can have central
infrastructure um
like we actually have here is our
processing platform
which is operated by a central team
without actually needing to involve them
in every single business process that is
built on top of that
and here we really went with association
between
decentral storage and central
infrastructure
and for that matter also with ownership
which was much increased already
by the decentral storage um together
with the central governance
because we already had these processes
in place that were actually
operating very well throughout the
company and after all
we also just had to realize that
interoperability
is created through convenient solutions
of a self-service platform
this was like a little bit of a
reflection on the technical things that
we did and now
i also want to uh add some more things
that
change on the behavioral side and that
we tried to foster in terms of behavior
um towards um towards our colleagues and
the different teams
once more short recap we were coming
from the situation where the data sets
were provided through central pipelines
by this data agnostic infrastructure
team so there was no clear ownership
there was lack of quality
uh but we wanted to really have the
possibility
um to give more power and also more
responsibility
um to the producers of the data to not
just be by-product producers but
actually be
owners of actual data products
first thing that we started to actually
ensure data quality was
we asked the people to make conscious
decisions
we came from the background of just
archiving every data set from a specific
data source
but a lot of the producers of these
datasets some of them didn't even know
that these data sets were archived
and accidentally then somebody also
started using these data sets and
accidentally they started building up
production processes on top of that
and accidentally there was an accident
that everything
instead of continuing with this
particular behavior we
just wanted to actually ask the people
to make conscious decisions
of what are the data sets that should be
archived and that should actually be
made available
for analytics so we went away from this
solution of default storage of
everything and we ask the people to opt
in
for their particular data sets because
once actually
actively opted in to store their data
sets then you at least
know that there's an awareness on the
producing side
that there is a data set that is stored
and archived and that there is the
potential
that people are actually using that
speaking of usage this was actually the
big part that we started to look into we
already had
tons of data sets as i said thousands of
data sets petabytes of data
that we were already storing in the
central data
so we started to have a look at the
actual usage statistics for these data
sets
we figured out there was a lot of data
sets actually the majority of them
which were never used at all and this of
course was a huge liability
not just in terms of costs well you are
paying for this data that you're
actually storing
and trust me s3 is a very nice and very
cheap option for data but when you're
talking about petabytes of data it
starts adding up
also it be viability in terms of
compliance
if these data sets now contain customer
information for instance
they all of a sudden become a part of
gdpr processing and you need to take
care of them
in additional ways as well so these were
the first things that we wanted to
tackle and really figure out
uh separate the ones so that we can
understand
what are the data sets that we even
potentially couldn't get rid of
both in terms of cost saving
measurements but also in terms of
increasing the compliance because those
data sets were not adding
any value at all the second class was
then of course some data sets
used not super frequently but maybe a
couple processes were running on them
that's usually then a fine situation to
just leave it like that
but most importantly we also found these
third class of data sets
which were usually just like a very
small portion of the data sets that we
had stored
which were heavily used like those were
the golden data sets that tons of these
were based on
that like the majority of your machine
learning use cases were running on
that a lot of reports were generated on
and they were used for
many many downstream processes
identifying these data sets now also
gives you an option to say this data is
so valuable
that it actually makes sense for the
company to dedicate additional resources
in providing this data really as a
product
but also increasing the quality maybe
even
um work much more into the direction of
product thinking that
we've earlier described in terms of
identifying what is my product actually
about what's my unique sales point
but also just the user happiness
um just to serve the consumers of your
data sets
and we were essentially asking for these
behavioral
changes from the data producers because
um it
should become this product that is not
just a byproduct that is
produced by accident as i already saw
ever said before
uh by understanding this usage of your
data
and by having these conscious decisions
um of
actually providing your data and making
it available to the people
we then also enabled the data producers
to actually dedicate resources
not only to understand the usage but
also to
ensure the quality because in the end
the data quality
for us really became a contract between
the consumers and the producers
only if there's enough demand for
actually increasing the quality and if
there's enough
value that is actually generated through
the data product that you are providing
uh then it makes sense to invest a lot
of time
and additional resources resources to
the issues you're providing here these
were
the things that we were changing in the
company to foster
behavioral changes uh most of the times
on the
data producer side um but what i also
want to give you
on the before we are closing out this
talk here is
what are the things that we are
currently tinkering with what are the
things that
we plan to go deeper into the future um
and that's exactly where uh i just want
to give you a little bit of an overview
of two of the main points that uh that
we are actively working
to prepare for the um
data processing improvements and data
infrastructure improvements
for um for what we are having here
the first one is we are actually
actively working on a domain
enterprise architecture so what does
that actually mean well first of all we
actually need to define for ourselves
what actually is a domain and
of course then right away the next point
comes
um what are actually the
responsibilities
for the domains and once you have this
cleared out you then even need to
appoint
domain specific experts that become like
the first point of contact
when it comes to any kind of questions
related to the data process
to the to the data products of this
specific domain
and this is something that we are
currently actively working to define
um all these terminology uh inside of
the nando and then
to try to roll this out on a company
scale
to really have also a little bit of an
organizational change
to structure your data processing more
and more
into these domains and apply this domain
driven thinking here also on the data
aspects
the second big point that i also want to
want to mention here is off-the-shelf
products so what we want to have and
this goes again much more into the
into this idea the data infrastructure
platform
is you don't want to have centrally
operated services anymore
but you want to have tools that people
can just
use into the other tools that they are
already using
um and just operate by themselves and
then have the full responsibilities of
the processes they are actually running
one of the things that we are currently
working on is we want to decentralize
the archiving of the data
instead of having the central processing
pipelines which are
public which are consuming thousands of
data sets
and are archiving them um going much
more with this opt-in approach that i
said
uh to also actually enable the people to
archive data sets by themselves
and again make them available um through
the central government afterwards
and then we also want to work towards
what i like to call
template-driven data preparation where
you essentially can have
certain uh let's smart jobs which are
already prepared to work on very common
patterns
there are certain processes and
operations that a lot of teams are
essentially reinventing every day like
re-partitioning data
like transforming data from let's say
json to a binary format
and all these there's like many many
more of these kind of uh
jobs which are done over and over again
and for these you
want to have some things like templates
where people that only need to adjust
the part that is very specific to their
particular use case
but all the stuff that just
needs these centralized processes they
can just essentially
plug and play for that regard that was
a little bit of the outlook of the
things that we are currently tinkering
with
and with that i actually want to close
it out this was data mesh and practice
i'm max schulze and i was joined today
by arief lita
to talk to you about how europe's
leading online platform for fashion
goes beyond the data lake thank you for
your attention
and we are open to receive any questions
either here in this chat or
also via the slack room thank you
yes thanks a lot everyone